Traduttore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Revisore: Chiara Angori
I ghiacciai sono i migliori indicatori
dei cambiamenti climatici.
Chissà quante volte l'avrete sentito dire.
Sempre vengono richiamati i ghiacciai
ogni volta che si parla
di problemi globali,
di problemi ambientali globali,
come in questi giorni.
Ma spesso non si dice che cosa sono,
e non si danno delle motivazioni
del perché dovrebbero essere
i migliori testimoni
del clima che cambia.
Attraverso l'incontro di oggi,
condividendo con voi la mia esperienza
e la mia passione,
spero di riuscire a svelarvi
qualcosa in più
su queste meravigliose ed effimere
presenze nelle nostre montagne
e di capire quindi se davvero
sono i migliori
a testimoniarci il clima che cambia.
Cominciamo con delle immagini.
Questo è un gigante
del Parco dello Stelvio:
il ghiacciaio dei Forni.
Questo ghiacciaio, in Lombardia,
è arretrato di oltre due chilometri
negli ultimi 150 anni.
Nello stesso periodo di tempo,
la temperatura dell'aria è aumentata
di poco meno di due gradi.
Certo, non è l'unico elemento
del mondo naturale,
dei sistemi naturali,
che risponde al clima che cambia.
Risponde anche la foresta,
innalzando il limite degli alberi,
rispondono gli animali e le piante,
andando incontro dapprima a degli stress,
e spesso rischiando l'estinzione.
Ma chi di noi è in grado di capire subito
che il limite della foresta
si sta alzando,
che un animale o una pianta sono vicini
all'estinzione.
Bisogna avere un occhio allenato, educato,
per cogliere queste peculiarità,
queste particolarità
dell'ambiente naturale.
Un arretramento, invece,
di oltre due chilometri è innegabile,
è chiaro a tutti, è limpido,
cristallino, inequivocabile,
e ci dice che qualcosa sta cambiando:
il clima.
I ghiacciai poi sono acqua in scatola.
Sono acqua allo stato solido,
annidata nelle nostre montagne,
che si rende disponibile
durante la fusione estiva
per mitigare soprattutto le magre
in periodi siccitosi,
ma anche per fornire
energia idroelettrica.
Che sia acqua in scatola è molto chiaro
in molti posti del mondo,
non solo alpini,
dove i ghiacciai sono molto più estesi,
ad esempio in Karakorum.
Questo è un villaggio del Pakistan
dove le persone compiono svariati viaggi
durante la settimana,
di parecchi chilometri,
per raggiungere il ghiacciaio,
prenderne dei blocchi,
che poi verranno utlizzati al villaggio
a scopo idropotabile.
Quindi davvero è acqua in scatola.
Il ghiaccio di ghiacciaio
è particolarissimo,
è diverso dal ghiaccio marino,
ad esempio, dal ghiaccio che possiamo
produrre noi nel freezer di casa.
Il ghiaccio marino,
il ghiaccio che produciamo noi,
è semplicemente acqua congelata.
Il ghiaccio di ghiacciaio
si forma molto lentamente,
con un processo di trasformazione,
di metamorfismo, della neve.
Così si chiama.
La neve precipita,
e quando precipita è leggera,
pesa solo 100 chilogrammi al metro cubo,
e poi si accumula, strato dopo strato,
e, se non fonde durante l'estate,
e sopravvive a un po' di estati,
si può trasfomare
in ghiaccio di ghiacciaio,
che ha una densità ben diversa,
917 chilogrammi al metro cubo.
Questo processo è lento,
ha bisogno di 10 anni circa sulle Alpi,
addirittura di un secolo in Antartide.
Grazie al fatto che il ghiaccio
deriva dalle nevicate,
rimane intrappolato al suo interno
anche molto altro,
soprattutto sostanze volatili
per lo più inquinanti,
per esempio detergenti,
ritardanti di fiamma, pesticidi,
che viaggiano partendo dalle nostre città
o dalle campagne in atmosfera,
raggiungono le alte vette
e lì precipitano insieme alla neve
e si trasformano in ghiaccio.
Quindi il ghiacciaio, da una parte,
tiene memoria anche del nostro
impatto chimico sull'ambiente,
quindi non solo dell'impatto sul clima,
e dall'altra questi inquinanti
prima o poi vengono rilasciati
quando il ghaccio fonde,
e in questi anni sta fondendo
molto intensamente,
quindi noi li ritroviamo poi nei fiumi,
nei laghi, nei mari,
e anche nei piatti di cibo di casa nostra,
perché poi entrano
nella catena alimentare.
Il ghiacciaio non sta fermo, si muove.
Si muove per scivolamento e deformazione,
e questo è evidente se ci si va sopra -
sono bellissimi i ghiacciai -
perché sono solcati da crepacci,
da fratture, che sono conseguenza
proprio della deformazione del ghiaccio
per il movimento.
Questa è una proprietà incredibile.
Pensate, non ci sono altri elementi
del paesaggio fisico che si muovano.
Invece il ghiacciaio si muove.
Certo, non ce ne accorgiamo,
si muove di pochi centimetri al giorno,
che vuol dire qualche decina
di metri all'anno,
ma si muove.
Allora, potreste dirmi,
"Ma come mai non li vediamo avanzare,
non li vediamo arrivare nelle valli?"
Non li vediamo arrivare nelle valli
perché durante l'estate
l'aria calda che ormai prevale
con il cambiamento climatico
fa sì che vada incontro a fusione
più ghiaccio
di quello che arriva grazie al movimento.
Quindi noi vediamo un accorciamento
continuo dei ghiacciai,
anche se loro si muovono,
e continuamente scendono
verso di noi, verso le valli.
Di che colore è il ghiaccio glaciale?
Immagino che tutti voi
pensiate sia bianco
o qualcuno blu,
perché nell'immaginario comune
il ghiaccio di ghiacciaio è bianco,
i ghiacciai sono candidi e immacolati.
E invece, guardate queste foto.
Questi sono i ghiacciai di casa nostra,
di Lombardia.
Sono grigiastri, marroncini,
perché si stanno annerendo.
È un fenomeno globale
che si chiama darkening.
I ghiacciai cambiano pelle, si anneriscono
a seguito del cambiamento climatico,
perché le pareti rocciose
hanno delle perdite di detrito,
delle frane, più frequenti,
e quindi si ammantano di detrito,
e a seguito anche del nostro impatto
sull'ambiente,
perché la fuligine, il particolato
derivante dai motori diesel,
piuttosto che dagli incendi boschivi,
rendono il ghiaccio sempre più grigio.
E questo è un problema.
Voi d'estate, per esempio,
come preferite vestirvi?
In genere sotto il sole
ci vestiamo di colori chiari.
Perché? Perché, ovviamente,
in questo modo riflettiamo di più
la radiazione solare
e avvertiamo di meno la calura.
Ecco, i ghiacciai non possono
scegliere i loro vestiti.
D'estate sono sempre vestiti di scuro,
assorbono continuamente di più
la radiazione solare,
si riscaldano di più,
e fondono molto, molto intensamente.
Questo è evidente confrontando delle foto
come quelle che vi propongo,
ma è ancora più evidente
applicando delle tecnologie nuove,
come il telerilevamento,
che vuol dire osservare
la terra dallo spazio
utilizzando satelliti, aerei e droni.
Noi con i satelliti, per esempio,
abbiamo studiato i ghiacciai
del Parco dello Stelvio.
I ghiacciai del Parco dello Stelvio
sono passati dal 17%
di copertura detritica nel 2003,
ad oltre il 30 % nel 2012.
Quindi un annerimento,
un darkening, evidente.
Sempre i satelliti ci dicono
non solo quanti ghiacciai sono neri,
ma anche quanto meno riflettono
la radiazione solare.
L'abbiamo fatto
per il Parco dello Stelvio dal 1987,
con delle immagini satellitari pioniere,
fino ai giorni nostri,
e abbiamo visto che effettivamente
la riflettanza diminuisce,
e i ghiacciai sono sempre più neri
e fondono sempre più intensamente.
Ora una domanda -
questo è il nostro drone,
con cui studiamo i ghiacciai
con estrema risoluzione,
e ci conferma questo annerimento.
Ora una domanda:
quanti ghiacciai ci sono in Italia?
Quanti sono?
Sono qualche decina,
qualche centinaio?
Vi sto parlando di qualcosa
che è raro e poco diffuso
o di qualcosa che è molto presente
sulle nostre montagne?
Qualche decina, ho sentito.
E allora vi stupirò.
I ghiacciai in Italia,
e li abbiamo inventariati con un catasto,
un catasto che non veniva più fatto
da sessant'anni
che con il mio gruppo di ricerca
abbiamo prodotto,
sono 903.
903 ghiacciai di cui 902 sulle Alpi
e uno solo è in Appennino,
il ghiacciaio del Calderone
nel gruppo del Gran Sasso.
Sono molto piccoli.
Pensate che tutti insieme si estendono
a coprire la superficie del lago di Garda,
368 km², per darvi un'idea
di quanto sia questo numero.
E si sono ridotti
negli ultimi sessant'anni
del 30 %,
che vuol dire 157 km²,
che è più o meno la superficie
del lago di Como.
Il loro numero invece è aumentato,
e questo sembra un controsenso.
Uno può dire, "Ma come?
Ci stai dicendo che i ghiacciai
si sono ridotti,
che la loro superficie è così ridotta,
e sono aumentati di numero."
Certo, perché aumentano
le finestre rocciose
e queste ovviamente portano
alla frammentazione del ghiacciaio
e alla produzione
di tanti ghiacciai piccoli
a partire da pochi ghiacciai grandi,
come in questo caso.
Ora, l'acqua che deriva dai ghiacciai
è davvero importante?
È un quantitativo sensibile,
oppure è poca?
Per rispondere a questo,
abbiamo confrontato del materiale
sempre da telerilevamento,
per la regione Lombardia
tra il 1981 e il 2007.
Abbiamo scelto queste due date
perché per queste due date
avevamo a disposizione
del materiale ad altissima risoluzione.
È emerso che in questo periodo di tempo
i ghiacciai di Lombardia si sono ridotti
di 1,5 km³ di ghiaccio,
che vuol dire 1496 miliardi
di litri di acqua in 26 anni.
Questo numerone,
se lo dividiamo per i 26 anni,
ci dà 57,5 milioni di m³
di acqua all'anno,
che i nostri ghiacciai non hanno perso,
ci hanno donato, hanno rilasciato
nel periodo estivo.
È tanto o è poco?
Per riuscire a dire
se era tanto o poco,
dobbiamo confrontare questo numero
con tutta l'acqua che precipita
in Lombardia durante l'anno.
Sotto forma di neve o di pioggia,
in Lombardia precipitano 27 miliardi
di m³ di acqua,
quindi 57 milioni contro 27 miliardi
sono una lacrima,
una lacrima che però precipita
nel periodo più importante,
quando effettivamente dobbiamo mitigare
le magre e i periodi siccitosi.
Ora, un'altra domanda che ci siamo posti
è se quest'acqua
ha un ruolo importante per la produzione
di energia idroelettrica.
Per fare questo, con il Politecnico,
nostro partner,
abbiamo valutato la produzione
di energia idroelettrica
nella provincia di Sondrio
negli ultimi 26 anni,
quantificando quanta acqua arrivava
dalla fusione nivale,
quanta acqua arrivava
dalla fusione glaciale
e dalle piogge.
Abbiamo diviso la provincia
di Sondrio in due aree:
in un'area c'erano solo ghiacciai e dighe
e nell'altra non c'erano i ghiacciai
ma c'erano comunque le dighe.
I nostri conti hanno evidenziato
che nel settore
dove erano presenti i ghiacciai,
le dighe si sono giovate
fino al 20 %
dell'acqua di fusione glaciale
per la produzione di energia.
È un quantitativo modesto il 20 %,
ma pensate tra qualche anno,
quando non ci saranno più i ghiacciai:
questo 20 % verrà a mancare
e dovremo fare i conti.
Alpi senza ghiacciai?
È possibile.
Purtroppo è possibile.
Se non cambieremo radicalmente
le nostre abitudini,
passando a delle forme più sostenibili,
sostenendo l'economia circolare,
andremo sempre più ad aumentare
i gas serra in atmosfera,
modificheremo il clima
e andremo incontro
a una riduzione dei ghiacciai
fin quasi alla loro scomparsa.
Possiamo fare qualcosa?
Sicuramente sì.
Pochi sanno che l'Italia,
applicando politiche di riduzione
delle emissioni,
già ha ridotto del 15 %
le emissioni di gas serra.
Certo questo non basta.
Dobbiamo aggiungere e fare qualcos'altro
anche noi, ogni singolo cittadino.
Per aiutarci in questo,
con il mio dipartimento
di Scienze e Politiche Ambientali,
abbiamo prodotto un test
di autovalutazione
proposto a tutti i cittadini
e postato sul sito web,
dove in forma anonima ciascuno di noi,
rispondendo a delle semplici domande,
può quantificare il suo impatto sul clima,
la sua impronta climatica,
così si chiama.
Quindi, rispondendo alle domande
in forma anonima,
che sono relative al riscaldamento,
all'illuminazione, ai trasporti,
all'alimentazione e
a come ricicliamo i rifiuti,
si può capire quanti CO2 equivalenti
emettiamo ogni anno.
La proposta è di fare il test,
ognuno di noi,
e poi di rifarlo una seconda volta
modificando qualcuna delle risposte
per capire come possiamo
risparmiare immissioni
semplicemente cambiando
le nostre abitudini,
e come possiamo anche risparmiare
nel nostro portafoglio,
perché sicuramente è più conveniente
aiutare il clima
e ridurre le nostre emissioni
di gas clima-alteranti.
Ora spero, dopo questo incontro,
di aver acceso o riacceso
la vostra passione,
il vostro interesse per i ghiacciai,
spero che ciascuno di voi trovi il tempo
per andare a vedere un ghiacciaio,
magari anche solo
dalla terrazza di un rifugio,
ricordandovi, quando lo ammirate,
che non sarà lì per sempre,
ma lì adesso, ora,
per ricordarci che il pianeta, il creato,
ci sono affidati e dobbiamo averne cura.
Grazie.
(Applausi)